[Music]
he was one of the most fearsome warlords
who ever lived waging an unstoppable
conquest across the Eurasian continent
but was Genghis Khan a vicious barbarian
or a unifier who paved the way for the
modern world we'll see in history vs.
Genghis Khan order order now who's a
defendant today
car
on I see your honor is familiar with
Genghis Khan the 13th century warlord
whose military campaigns killed millions
and left nothing but destruction in
their wake
objection first of all it's pronounced
chingus Han really in Mongolia yes
regardless he was one of the greatest
leaders in human history born
Temujin he was left fatherless and
destitute as a child but went on to
overcome constant strife to unite
warring Mongol clans and forge the
greatest empire the world had seen
eventually stretching from the Pacific
to Europe's heartland and what was so
great about invasion and slaughter
northern China lost two-thirds of its
population the Jin dynasty had long
harassed the northern tribes paying them
off to fight each other and periodically
attacking them dschinghis Han wasn't
about to suffer the same fate as the
last Han who tried to unite the Mongols
and the demographic change may reflect
poor census keeping not to mention that
many peasants were brought into the Hans
army you can pick apart numbers all you
want but they wiped out entire cities
along with their inhabitants the Han
preferred enemies to surrender and pay
tribute but he firmly believed in
loyalty and diplomatic law the cities
that were massacred were ones that
rebelled after surrendering or killed
his ambassadors his was a strict
understanding of justice multiple
accounts show his Army's brutality going
beyond justice ripping unborn children
from mothers wombs using prisoners as
human shields or moat fillers to support
siege engines taking all women from
conquered towns enough how barbaric is
that really so much worse than other
medieval armies that doesn't excuse
Genghis Khan's atrocities but it does
make chingus Han unexceptional for his
time rather than
some bloodthirsty savage in fact after
his unification of the tribes abolished
bride kidnapping women in the mongol
ranks had it better than most they
controlled domestic affairs could
divorce their husbands and were trusted
advisors Temujin remained with his first
bride all his life even raising her
possibly illegitimate son as his own
regardless genghis khan's legacy was a
disaster up to 40 million killed across
Eurasia during his descendants conquests
10 percent of the world population
that's not even counting casualties from
the Black Plague brought to Europe by
the Golden Horde siege of kapha surely
that wasn't intentional
actually when they saw their own troops
dying of the plague they catapulted
infected bodies over the city walls
well the accounts you're referencing
will written over a hundred years after
the fact how reliable do you think they
are plus the survivors reaped the
benefits of the Empire chingus on
founded benefits the Mongol Empire
practiced religious tolerance among all
subjects they treated their soldiers
well promoted based on merit rather than
Birth established a vast postal system
and enforced universal rule of law not
to mention their contribution to culture
you mean like Hulagu cons annihilation
of Baghdad the era's cultural capital
libraries hospitals and palaces burned
irrigation canals buried Baghdad was
unfortunate but its Khalif refused to
surrender and Hulagu was later punished
by barre ke Han for the wanton
destruction
it wasn't Mongol policy to destroy a
culture usually they saved doctors
scholars and artisans from conquered
places and transferred them throughout
their realm spreading knowledge across
the world what about the devastation of
Kiev on roofs leaving its people in the
dark ages even as the Renaissance spread
across Western Europe
Western Europe was hardly peaceful at
the time the stability of Mongol rule
made the Silk Road flourish once more
allowing trade and cultural exchange
between East and West and its legacy
forged Russia and China from warring
princedoms into unified States in fact
long after the empire chingus Hans
descendants could be found among the
ruling nobility all over Eurasia not
surprising that a tyrant would inspire
further tyrants careful what you call
him you may be related what 16 million
men today are descended from Chingiz
Homme that's one in every 200 for every
great Conqueror there are millions of
conquered whose stories will survive and
can a leaders historical or cultural
significance outweigh the deaths they
caused along the way these are the
questions that arise when we put history
on trial
[Music]